- I don't know who Jenna Marbles is.
I don't know what she does.
I don't know Jenna Marbles.
- That sounds like a poem.
(upbeat music)
- Wow, there's 15 million subscribers?
- Maybe she does beauty stuff.
- Workout videos.
Something with animals.
(upbeat music)
- If you were born really ugly like me,
have no fear, there's steps you can take
to be good looking, kind of.
- She's not ugly.
- She's great, right?
She's like a beach model.
- I'm surprised at how hard
she's being on herself.
- She's mad witty and self
deprecating, which I like.
- I do like that she's like,
putting herself out there.
I mean, like, I have a retainer.
That's like, makes me feel better
that I also have a retainer.
- It's like funny, because we've all like,
said that kind of stuff where you've like,
looked in the mirror and been like,
oh my god, like, what's happening.
- Yeah.
- Her commentary on the
flaws in our society
are like, spot on.
And she does it in a way that doesn't seem
like she has an agenda
and it makes you laugh.
- Yeah, my eyelashes are so real.
I don't wear fake lashes.
- There's a lot of boobs.
- There is some boob.
- I (bleep) say that all the time.
- This is a video that probably guys watch
and they're like, amen.
- This videos like three minutes long
and apparently there's
(bleep) ton girls lie about.
This is news to me.
- Yeah, we lie about a lot of (bleep).
- The thing is, men always ask like,
what's wrong, when they know what's wrong
and you're like nothing, 'cause you need
to tell me what's wrong.
- I don't know.
- This is also just
like, boom, boom, boom.
Like, instantly paying off.
- I hear if you kiss someone,
you trade faces with them.
- [Together] What!
- She looks like she's genuinely
having the best time ever.
- And she's relatable.
Like, she's a relatable person.
Like, I would hang out with this girl.
- Whoa, I wanna face swap my
face onto different things.
- I think if, Abraham
Lincoln like, saw this video,
he would just be like, what are you doing
America with your time?
- She's taking the face
swap to the next level.
- Yeah, to an extreme level.
- I think she's carving
out her own little piece
in the world to be funny
in and do the thing
she wants to do because if that's like,
authentically her, no one's
telling her what to do
and the fact that she's
making such relatable content
is like, really, really great.
- I think people take
themselves so seriously,
so I think people probably go watch her
so they can like, laugh at
themselves and her altogether.
- You know, I always wanted to put like,
a jar of marbles in my
mouth and I never could.
I never did.
I just need that.
- Wait, which one is it?
- You couldn't or you never did?